okay
[Music]
I'm Gonna Fly ah let's do this yeah
you gotta force it to come out what are
you
you're a genius I know what'd I say
oh did you know what was gonna happen to
my brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
acquired who said that systems
[Music]
threat eliminated
we think the government is going to do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
it belongs to me
listen to me
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal had anything
pleased
yeah that's more like it
oh yeah
I love you feel for your family makes
you weak you're wrong my family that's
what makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
[Music]
you're the Blue Beetle is that could use
that Arsenal right about now God you
never asked oh yeah
Bust It Down bust it down
I advise me back away